サッバパパスアカラナン クサラッソウパサンパダ
サチッタパリヨダパナン エータン ブッダナサーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
今日は少々時間遅れまして大変申し訳ございません
えーと 私に聞かないで道路を工事始めてやったんです
はい まあそういうことで
今日のテーマに入りましょう
結果を出すチーム力ということで
あの 組織についてね うまく活動する組織もあります
うまく活動しない組織ってあるということを説明したい
したがっていただろうと思いますけど
そういうことに答えるよりは
仏教的に見る組織とは何なのかという
私は仏教の話をしたいと思います
それから内容なんですけど
皆様方はもう聞き慣れている
聞き飽きている内容になります
細かい 今まで私は発表していないいろいろ内容
データがあるんだけども
そうするとあまりにも細かすぎくなりますから
全体的なテーマとしてはちょっと扱いにしにくいところもございます
そういうところで大雑把に仏教の組織論を考えてみましょう
一番最初にいるのは この
調和とか和合という組織にどうしても欠かせない条件ですね
これは結構厳しいものなんですね
この理由は 簡単に実現できないからこそ
皆この二言葉を大事にしています
私たちはものすごい尊い単語であって
尊い言葉って尊いアイデアというふうにすごく褒め称えていますね
この調和と和合というのはね
こんなに人間がなんで褒め称えてありがたいありがたいと思ってますかというと
現実的にないからなんです
これやっぱり仏教を学ぶ人々として理解してください
私たちはあまりもうるさく
何かスローガン的に使っているならば
現実的にはそれがないんです
だから希望的に欲しいだけなんです
だから常に調和だったら
そんなに調和あれやこれやとこう言う必要はないんですよ
常に和合があるんだったら
なんだこれって当たり前ということで面白くなくなっちゃうんです
だから これかなり立派な単語になっているのは
我々の文化の中で それは実際調べてみるとないからなんです
生命には自我という錯覚があります
人間だけじゃなくて どんな生命にも
この錯覚 認識のところでちょっとおかしい出来事が起きちゃって
錯覚が起きてるんですね
これは自我という錯覚なんですね
物事を自分中心にしか見えないんです
だから自我の錯覚があるんだから
この自我という色眼鏡でしか物事を見えないんです
見ようとしても 私に見える世界
私が考える世界 私に聞こえる世界なんですね
我々のあるのはいつだって私がそう思います
私がこう思います 私はこのように見ましたという主語が私っていうのはどうしても入ります
だからこれはどうしようもないことなんですよ
あの人にこのように見えますっていうことは言えないでしょう
あの人ならこのように考えますよって
これ言えないんですね
私がこのように考えますということしかないんです
価値観も自我中心です
それで我々の世界にある価値観というのは
すべて各人の自我中心的な価値観なんです
人が何かを評価しても
それは私が評価するかしないか別な話で
人が評価することは私も評価するならば
それは私の価値観であって
その人の価値観ではないんです
自分に利益がある時だけ
他人に仲良くしようとするんです
はい そういうことで 自分の利益を考えて
人は あるいは生命は他の生命と他の人となんとかコミュニケーションを取ろう
仲良くしようと思っているんです
だから人が人と話す場合でも
動物の世界でも 仲良くしようと思うならば
その仲良くしようと活動している生命体が自分の利益を考えているんです
したがって 和合とか調和とか和合とか
決して簡単なものではありません
だからみんな自分のことしか考えていないんだから
どうやって調和するんですかね
どうやって和合というものを保たれる
持てますかね これ 簡単ではありません
かなり難しい はい 次 チームってどういうものかと
私はこういう言葉より組織という言葉を使いますが
目的は同じか似ているならば
それは一人で達成できないならばチームを組むんです
要するに 私に私のエゴで何か目的があるんですね
でも 一人だけではその目的に達する達成することはできません
目的があっても なかなか人の協力なければ成り立たないんですね
それで じゃあチームを組もうとするんです
いたって簡単な例で考えましょうか
例えば 自分がいくらか収入を得たいと思って
屋台 ラーメン屋さんでも作ろうとする
これはあくまでもその人だけの商売でしょ
でも ラーメン屋さんをやったんだからといって
お客さんが来てラーメンを食べなきゃ収入が入らないでしょうに
だから目的に達成達成しないでしょう
そうするとお客さんと仲良くしようとするんです
ああ 元気ですかねとかね
あれやこれやとか機嫌をとって
いい雰囲気を作ろうとしているんです
その屋台 ラーメン屋さんのところに集めたら
みんななんとなく温かい穏やかな雰囲気ができている
そうすると みんなラーメン食べてお金払って
その人のいくらか生計を立てるために金が欲しいという目的が実現できますね
客が来ても来なくてもどうでもいいやということでは
これは成り立たないんですね
だけど 至って簡単なことなんです
それは理解することは簡単です
我々は各個人に何か目的
利益が目的がある それが自分一人だけでは成り立たない
そういうことで仲良くする
学校に出て学びたいならば
教師と仲良くしなくちゃいけないし
仲間とも仲良くしなくちゃいけないんですね
教師も仲間も馬鹿にして無視して学校で学ぶということは成り立たないんです
はい そういうわけで チームというのはその決まりで成り立つものなんです
各個人の目的は同一 れません
問題はそこに起こりますよ
目的同等 同格 同レベルにならないんです
同じ子供二人が勉強したいなと試験合格したいと思っても
勉強したい 試験を合格したいというのは言葉では同じですよ
でも本当は違うんです
このその人々が目指している目的が同等にならないんです
例えば  3人が同じ目的を作る
晩御飯 何か美味しい晩御飯を食べましょうよと
あ  3人とも同じ目的や
違いますよ だって 3人が美味しい晩御飯というのは何なのかと
それによって変わるんですよ
ある人はかなり豪華で大量のものを食べたくなる
ある人はすごく簡単なもので晩御飯を済ましたくなる
いろいろでしょう だから我々は同じ目的があってチームを組みますけど
この 3人でご飯を食べようと
じゃあ一緒に行きましょうという場合は
食べたいものによって喧嘩になるんですね
私はあのお店がいいやと思います
いや 私はこのお店がいいやとかね
そこでどうなるかというと
個人差が必ずあります
ですから エゴがぶつかります
チームの中に問題が起きます
それで問題が起きます
一人があのお店がね すごく落ち着いて
あまりにも人が来ない
すごい中もすごい綺麗で落ち着く
純和風の 店だから そちらで行って気持ちよく贅沢な気分を味わってご飯を食べましょうと
もう一人 いえ 私はものすごい食いたいんだよと
ものすごくお腹が減ってるんだよ
例えば男性がいて だからどこかあのお店ではね
あのディナーのブッフェありますからね
そちらに行きましょうと
ただ この人は いえ それはいいんだけど
そちら人がいっぱいいるし
並んでいなくちゃいけないし
座るところを見つかるかないかもわからないしね
うるさいし なんか気持ち悪いやと
もうこの 3人のチームがそこで
いろいろ議論が生じているんです
自我の利害関係でしかチームは組まないんです
よく覚えてください このチームというのは自我の利害関係なんです
例えば 私には嫌な人々がいて
何かその人々に攻撃したいんですね
人々を何か邪魔をしたいんです
一人ではできない それで同じ気持ちある何人かとチームを組んでいじめ作業を始めるんです
でも 私の仲間に入った人々も
私と同じぐらい この相手のことを嫌いかというと
そちらに差があるんです
ある人はあなたが言ったんだから参加しましたよと
本当は私は忙しいんだよと
もう一人はね そんな程度で軽いいじめは私には気に入らんやと
私ならぶん殴りますよと
それでもう一人 いえいえ
それは法律的な問題ですからね
そこはいくらやめましょう
こういう 3人でね 人をいじめるためにチームを組んだっても
そのチームの中でもトラブルがというか
問題が起きてしまいます
だから問題っていうのは
我ががあんまり成り立ってない
ちょっと危うい状態になります
はい 私はこの変な例だったんだからといって
世界はそんなもんではないと思わないでください
世界いつだってそういうことなんです
誰だってチームを組んだら
そういう問題に遭遇しなくちゃいけないんです
組織のマネジメントは運命的な問題ですね
ここで英語の単語を使えば
それマネジメントなんですね
だから組織ができたら
このマネジメントというものは必要ない
だから何人がいるんだからね
いろんなことをマネジメントしなくちゃあかんです
これはものすごい難しいんです
理由は自我なんです 人にはセルフマネジメントさえもできないんです
そこで組織マネジメントするどころか
自分一人だけ 自分一人だけのこともマネジメントできないんですよ
我々は 自分で自己の管理さえできないのに
どうやって 3人  4人  10人
20人まとめて管理できるんですかね
話にならない だから日本は和合や調和やらえらい自慢するんだけど
私が聞いているところの話によると
ほとんど皆様方は会社で仕事をしているでしょうに
いつでも何か部下のあれやこれやとか
上司のあれやこれや 誰だっていろいろな愛を持ってるんですよ
みんな持ってます 自分の会社ではこういうもう上司のこれこれ
部下のこれこれというね
で これって珍しいことではないんです
なぜならば セルフマネジメントさえできない人々は
他人をマネジメントしようとしているんですね
次に チームの力って何ですかと
目的は良かれ悪かれ 一人で実現できるものは少ない
これは世の中の常識 私個人の目的はどうでもいいんです
良い目的であろうか 悪い目的か
それは関係ないんです
私は何か目的があるんです
しかし 一人でできるということはね
これはないんですよ たった一人でできることっていうのはないわけじゃないんだけどね
例えば喉が渇いたんだから水を飲むとかね
まあそんな程度では一人でできますけど
朝出勤しなくちゃいけないんだから
自分一人で起きましたとかね
そんな程度なんですよ
一人でできるものは 他の目的の場合は
他人の力も必要になります
例えば結婚している場合は
もう朝 6時半に出かけたい
それで仕事はもうかなり11時
2時までもう一発で進む
ということは 朝ごはんを食べて行った方がいい
朝ごはん抜くわけにはいきません
なぜならば 昼もご飯を食べる時間がない
そうすると その人は奥さんに言うんですね
朝 6時に出発しなきゃいけないんだから
朝ごはん用意してくれと
それで奥さんが 5時ぐらいで起きて
朝ごはんを作って用意して
6時あたりで旦那さんを起こさなくちゃあかんですね
旦那が起きてさっさと着替えて
食卓に来ると ちゃんとご飯は用意してあって
それ食べて終わるともう 6時半ですね
後片付けはそんな時間もないんですね
だから それで本人が自分の目的に達したんだけど
もう一人とチームを組んだんです
目的に達するために 一人ではできないんです
ということで 各人の目的
良し悪しかれ それはどうでもいいことで
目的に達したければ 目的を実現したければ
チームを組まなくてはいけないというなんか
ややこしいんですよ 人生は
二人三人のように人の数が増えれば
実行できる力が現れます
例えば 奥さんが 5時に起きてほしいんだけど
子供がもしかすると徹夜して勉強をしている
受験中で そうすると お母さんには子供にね
あんた 5時ぐらい私を起こしてくれと頼むことはできます
もしかすると 目覚まし時計の声で自分が疲れてるんだから
目が覚めない可能性もあります
しかし 自分の子供 お母さん
お母さんって言うと ガクッと目が覚めます
いくらなんでも そうなってくると
このチームにはもう 3人が入ってるんですね
子供に至っても お母さんが早く起きた方が
何か飲み物でも作ってくれたりするんだから
これも楽しいということで
大体どんなことでも一人でやるよりは二人でやった方が楽 ３
人もいた方が楽っていうこともあります
しかし それは複雑です
必ず数が増えてわけではいいわけ
増えてよかれということじゃないんです
数がありすぎてうまくいかない
いかないこともいくらでもありますね
だからこの目的に合わせた人の数なんですよ
だから私たちもテーラワーダ協会で
みんなで集めていろいろ行事とかやってますから
で その場合は一つも一人でできない
この間 子供祭りも法要もありましたし
それは決して一人でできるものじゃない
しぶしぶウェーサーカ祭りもありますからね
お釈迦様のことはすごくみんな嫌いだからね
お釈迦様の誕生日をお祝いたくないんですね
だから誰が大泥棒の人の誕生日やろうと思ったら簡単にやってくれますけどね
だから私は考えて 今度からクリスマスやりましょう
テーラワーダ協会で そうすると日本全国にいる会員様方は参加する可能性はあります
お釈迦様なら嫌ですね
これはと まあそれは冗談で
そういうウェーサーカ祭りであろうか
子供祭りであろうか あるいは新年会で法要であろうか
これ一人でできるものじゃないでしょう
それで各お坊さんも参加しなくちゃいけないし
一般の方々も参加しなくちゃいけないし
で 祭りだからいくらかきれいな雰囲気を作らなくちゃいけないし
いろんな仕事が現れてくる
参加する人々の食事やら飲み物をどうしようかってことも出てくるし
それで一人でできないんだから
チームを組む 考えてください
それでゴータミ僧侶でしたっけ？ゴータミ僧侶で何か法要をやろうと思って
ちょっとお飾りをね しようとする
そちらに 40人ぐらいボランティア参加したらどうなるんですかね
できなくなるんです だってスペースが少ないでしょうに
玄関に何か旗を旗を張ったり
何か印刷したポスターを貼るためには 10人入れちゃってもね
何する？それで仕事もういかないんです
数がありすぎちゃって
しかし 数が少なくなると
すべての飾りは一人の担当になっちゃって
この人は買い物をして
いろんな品を持ってきて
それはいろいろな整理整頓して
玄関からまたどこか登るところも登って
旗を そちらもこれ１階で ２
階で階段 あれやこれやとかする
一人ではね 無理 そういうわけで
この仕事によって 何人でうまくいくのかっていうこともありますよ
ただ それは物質的な世界でね
人が多すぎて物事もういかないってことはあります
もう一つは この我々の気持ちの問題
例えば ゴータミに行って瞑想にでも参加したいなと思っても
自分一人でなかなかやる気が出てこない
出かける気が出てこない
そうすると そうするともう知ってる友達と話し合ったら
ああ そう あんた行きたいの
では一緒に行きましょうよと言うと
もう一人も来るんだから
もう行かない わけには行かなくなっちゃうんですね
そうすると二人で行って参加する
それでチームを組んだことによって
自分の気持ちが実行に移せるように強くなったんです
大体このデモとかね やっている場合は
あのデモに参加する人々の数が増えれば増えるほど
このデモをやっている人々がえらい元気になっちゃうんです
かなり調子に乗り上がっちゃって
何をやっているのかわからない
デモの目的と全く違うことをやるんです
調子に乗り上がっちゃって
例えばね 平和運動をやってやって暴動で終わるでしょ
火炎瓶投げたり 店を壊したり
あるいはたくさんの人が参加したことで気持ちがかなり強くなっちゃって
独裁政権倒そうと思って運動するでしょ
独裁政権でやられている一般人たちが
反政府デモに参加して
なおさら自分たちがやられちゃうんですよ
自分たちでも喧嘩するは
物を壊すは 店を壊すは
で 力 何て言いますか 舞い上がっちゃって
軍隊にも攻撃するわ そうなってきたら
かえってひどい目に遭ってしまうんですね
結局は政権倒すことはできなくなっちゃいますよ
あまりにも人を殺されて血を流しちゃいますから
だからそういうことでも
で この数は力なりという話なんですけど
これ 仏教的に見ると 数は力なりと言うなよと簡単に
例えば この机を向こうに運びたい
一人ではできませんね
それで数は力なりというのは
まあ二人で十分でしょう
本当は まあ二人にはちょっと重いんだから
あと二人 入ったら完璧
もう十二分です これにじゃあ 10人が入ったらどうしますか？この机をあちらに運ぶ 12
人が来たら これうまくいかないんですよ
もしかすると机は壊れる可能性もあります
ですから うかつに数は力なりと思わないでください
で 気持ちの場合も同じなんですよ
一人がいるよりは 二人
三人いると気持ちができて上がって
元気にはなります どんどん同じ目的で集め
例えばもう真面目に講演を聞こうと来る人がいるとしましょう
ないんだけど じゃあ推測でね
いるとしましょう その
その人だけがこちらに座って
私 が喋ると なんかおかしくてね
真剣に聞けないんですよ
それで5人 10人 20
人ぐらいいると まあまあで
もしこのホールがぎゅうぎゅうと人がいっぱいだとしましょう
そうすると逆にまた講演聞かないんです
あまりにも立っている
立ってる人もいるわ こちらもこちらもいるわ
もうみんなぎゅうぎゅうで座ってるわ
もうあれでこれで もう気があちらこちらに行ってしまっちゃって
で また講演に集中することができなくなっちゃうんです
だから必ず数は力なりではないんです
数に限りがあります いつでも物質的な労働をする時でも
数に限りがあります 精神的に高ぶってほしい場合でも
数限りがあります 期待する結果になる可能性は高くなります
だから必要な数が揃っちゃうと
結果出そうなということになるんですね
私は気をつけて この可能性が高くなりますと書くんです
決してこの期待する結果叶いますとは書きません
それまた微妙なんです
だからチームを組んだら結果OKということじゃないんです
大きい目的を実現するために大きい組織が必要です
国同士で組んだり 世界的なスケールで組んだりする必要もあります
それで次の問題は目的なんです
目的が大きくなると 小さな組織ではできません
目的が大きくなると 組織も大きくしなくちゃいけないんです
時々 国際的なスケールにしようとする
アメリカがどこかの国をね
攻撃する場合は アメリカの表で言っていることと裏の気持ちはものすごい隔たりがあるんだから
表では平和 民主主義 自由
なんだらかんだら 人権とかいろいろ言ってますからね
だから いとも簡単に嫌な国に全部爆弾を落として粉々にすることはできないんです
それで国連をいじって
いろいろ腰抜けの国々をいじって参加して
国際的な問題にするんです
イラク戦争は決して国際的な問題ではなかったんです
イラクに問題もなかったんです
初めから イラクの人がどんなイスラム国もね
独裁政権でしょうね イスラム国では民主主義はあんまりないんです
あの宗教から見れば 民主主義はあまりできないんです
不可能です 神様さえも独裁者だからね
だから まあ放っておけばいいですよ
我々にとっては関係ない
我々にとっては民主主義でいいんです
私たちは独裁主義は嫌なんです
だから放っておけばいいんです
しかし やりたいんだから
それは国際問題に仕立てる
そこで私に読めるのは
なるほど 一人でやっちゃうとまずいんだから
無理やりに強引にいくつかの国々を参加させる
参加させて 何の関係もない国を破壊すると
これ 第二次世界戦争の時でも同じことが起きたんですね
ドイツとそのグループの国々がどんどん力強くなって
科学的にもかなり進んで
やばいんですね 他の国々はそんな力がないんですよ
それがとんでもないことで
それでイギリスとかね
特にイギリスとその関係の国々
そこでまとめちゃって
また他の国々も参加してもらって
もうやっとアメリカもいやいやで参加して
もうなんとか連合体みたいなものを作って
もう攻撃して ドイツ政権というかね
ヒットラーの独裁政権を倒しちゃったんですね
それで国連などなどが現れてきましたけど
その時は敵同士でも仲良くしたでしょ
ロシア 中国 イギリス アメリカ
みんな仲良くしちゃったんです
敵同士なのに で 面白いでしょ
現象は 目的は大きい 一人で達成できません
では組みましょうと その時は敵とも組むんです
だから皆様方はチームの和合調はどうでしょうか？何考えているんですかね
そんなのはないんですよ
初めから はい まあ最後の文章は
世界スケールで組んだからといって
目的に目的が必ず叶うという保証はありません
だから世界の平和を何とかしようかなと思ってやってますけど
やればやるほど国同士の戦争がもうどんどん広がるだけなんですね
シリアやらもういろんな国
国で イラクも今もう新たな問題があってね
パキスタンもアフガニスタンもね
いろいろアメリカ入ってきていろんなことやっちゃったんだけど
結局は前よりも問題が悪化してしまっちゃったんです
解決できない状態になっちゃったんです
ですから ただ単に組んだからといって
組織が巨大だと すごい力ありますよと
では結果は？それ保証できません
はい 次のテーマに行きます
自我 いわゆるエゴの問題
このチームの中 なんでややこしくてうまくいかないんですかと
チームは二人のチームであろうか
10か国が集めたチームであろうか
G7 G8 G40といったことあるでしょうに
国連もあるでしょうに
うまくはいってないんです
どこでも その理由は 各個人のエゴなんです
一人一人のエゴという錯覚なんです
そこで調和を拒否するエゴイストのチームは
沼に建てるお城のようです
沼の上ではお城は建てられませんよ
だからエゴはバラバラだから
なんかチーム組んでもチームはいつ壊れるかわからない
やっとなんかチームのもどきで終わってしまうんです
それからお釈迦様の言葉
人間は不潔だと バジャンティセワンティチャカーナッタニッカーナドゥルッレバアッジャミッタアッタッタパンニャーアシュチーマヌッサーエーコーチャリーカッガヴィサーナカッ
ポ
これはスッタニパータの 75番目の偈なんですね
日本では仏教を知らなくても
スッタニパータの  ಅವರುたちがいくらでもいますからね
訳する必要もないんです
で 私の訳は 何かのわけがあって
いわゆる自我の利益ですね
人付き合いをするのです
いわゆる自我の利益があって
この利益を考えて 我々は人付き合いをやっているんだと
自利を目指さない付き合いは珍しいのです
だから 純粋清らかな人間関係っていうのはないんだよとお釈迦様が言ってるんです
自我の利益のみを目指す人は不潔ですと
ですから 聖者は犀の角のように一人で歩むと
なんで聖者が極端な一人生活するのかというと
そういうわけですよと
組めませんよと 誰とも
不潔ですからね これ インターネットで私はこの日本の方々の訳も必要だろうと
私の訳は一応否定されますので
一応訳を入れました このコピーペイで
で 今の人々は自分の利益のために
何でしたい？これはどう読みますか
交わりを結び また他人に奉仕する
奉仕するっていう言葉
元はないんだけどね 今日
今ですね 今日 利益を目指さない勇は得難い
自分の利益のみを知る人間は汚らしいでしたっけ
犀の角のようにただ一人歩めと
だからこの間違いなんで
この日本の究極な天才たちのたちの訳はね
犀の角のようにただ一人歩めではないんです
そうすると これ みんなに言ってるように聞こえるでしょうね
皆様に言って語ってないんです
この経典は 勘違いしてほしくないです
これは聖者が自分が語っているんです
聖者の生き方 聖者が発表しているだけ
汝そうしなさいと言ってないんです
だから歩めという訳も
文法的に間違いなんです
あれは動詞の勘違いなんですね
えいこちゃれと言えば歩めという命令形で読み取れますけど
歩むのである なんです
本当の意味は だから聖者が自分の心の内を発表しているだけで
だから聖者が一人で歩むものであるなんです
だから我々はそうですか
ありがたいねと理解すれば十分です
素晴らしいですねとかね
私たちは違いますねとかね
そこで日本はものすごいエゴイストの塊だから
誰にも理解しがたい スッタニパータ
すごい人気あるんです
理由は物の見事に誤解しているんだからなんです
俺は一人でやるぞとかね
エゴイスト以外何でもないんです
一人でやるとか なんだこれはと
できることならやってみなさいと言いたいんです
これは清らかな心の境地
解脱の世界 どんなものかと人間の言葉で聖者が発表しているんです
だからこの言葉っていうのはものすごい尊い言葉で
手を合わせてありがたく読んで理解するもので
うかつに使うものじゃないんです
はい  その話はどうでもいいんです
一応 人間は不潔であるということね
で ここでポイントは 不潔な人を非難することじゃなくて
人間のこのチームはいつだって自分の利益で成り立ってるんだよと最高の古い経典でも言ってるんです
美しい平和な調和を保つ和合を保つ組織やって何考えてるんですかね
そんなごまかしはよしましょうよと
本当のこと見ましょうよと
はい 次 自己管理 和合調和を考える前に自己管理が必要です
だからマネージメントはまず自分をマネージメントするところから始まるんです
チャンダドーサバーヤーモーハーヨーダンマンアティワッペティニヒーヤティ
ヤソーカーラパクケーはチャンディマ 1
チャンダ好み  2ドーサ怒り
3バイ恐懼  4モーヘ無知によって真理あるいは事実をねじ曲げる人の幸福は
欠けてゆく月のように減るんですと
それは自己管理でお釈迦様がおっしゃったことを
妻子妻家として俗世間にいるならば
幸せになりたいでしょ
だったらます セルフマネジメント
セルフマネジメント場合はポイント4つです
また4つありますけど
今日はそれを入れてないんです
我々は生きる時はいつでもチャンダで
チャンダっていうのは意欲とか訳しますけど
私はその専門の用語ではなくて
好みという言葉を使うんです
この場合は どうせ私たちは何かやっている時は
どうしても自分の好みによって考えて
好みに合わせる 判断する時でも好みに合わせる
へっちゃらで断る時言うでしょ
私の好みではありませんと
ですから この好みという
ものが我々でよく働きますよ
店を選ぶ時も好みがある
服を買う時でも好みがある
人付き合いの場合も好みがある
どうしようもないんですね
これは だから 現実で動かないんですよ
データで動いてないんです
好みで動くんです これで大きな問題ですよ
そんな簡単に解決できませんよ
住む場所も好みで決める
客観的なデータではないんですね
若い人々は就職先を選ぶ時でも
できるだけ好みで選ぶということもあるんですね
特に危険なのは判断する時なんです
判断する時は好みで判断しちゃうと
もう完全アウトなんです
だからなかなか たとえ学校の教師であっても
もういろんなトラブルがトラブルが起こるでしょ
それを解決する時は判断しなくちゃあかんでしょ
好みでやっちゃいます
正しい判断ではなくなっちゃうんです
ですから この好みっていうのは欲ということでも欲に
似てますけど なんか変ですね
2番目はどうせ怒りでやっちゃいます
それから怖いと 恐怖感が心にあると
もうやるべき判断はしません
4番目はまあアホということですね
無知 面倒くさい そんなのは考えるの面倒くさいんだからこうしましょうよと
無知で判断する こういうことで我々は事実
これでねじ曲げたんです
真理もねじ曲げるんです
で 現実から離れたら もうそちらに幸福あるわけじゃないんです
特に宗教の例出せば 人間というのは死にたくないという欲を持っています
だから死なない状況といっちゃうと
すぐその好みでそちらに行っちゃうんですね
死なない方法はあるのかと
それで死なないことはありえないんだから
宗教っていうのは必ず決まって嘘を言う書籍ですから
ありますよと 見せてちょうだいと
いえ 見せませんよ これはあんた死んでからなんですと
もう死んでから いらんですけどね
死にたくない人に死んでから永遠の命ってのは
それだけで理屈崩れてるでしょうに
我々は死にたくないんだから神様を信仰しているんですけど
でも神様が永遠の命を与えてくれるのは死んでからなんです
それでもみんな信じるんです
情熱的に どんどん こんなに科学が発展しているんだけど
宗教の方が前よりもすごい力強く
今世に広がっているんです
だからそれで人類は破滅になります
最終的には宗教から離れなくちゃいけないんです
で 例えば仏教の場合は
あのね 人だって誰でも死にますよと
人だけじゃないよと この宇宙でも破壊しますよと
いい加減にしろよ あんなの聞きたくないでしょ？好みじゃないでしょ
嫌なことを言うんだと
失礼なことを言うんだと
人を侮辱しているんだということになっちゃうんです
それで科学を知った人が幸福になるのに
幸福にならなくなっちゃうんです
宇宙だって破壊するんだっていうことは事実でしょうに
そういうことで これは宗教の例なんですね
だから世界では いくら宗教はどの宗教でも愛を謳っていますし
平和を謳っていますが
全部嘘で 宗教のおかげで世界戦争が起きるんですね
憎しみも起こるんですね
だからもう現実ではない
だから不幸なんですね
世の中はいつでも さらに不幸に不幸になっていくんです
だからそれで お釈迦様がおっしゃっているこれ
我々はこのある偏見を持ってますね
偏見は 4 タイプなんです
チャンダドーサバイモーハ
それは暗記した方がいいんです
チャンダドーサバヤモーハ
ヨーダンマンアティワッタティ
ニッイエティタッサヤソーカーラパクケーワチャンディマット
だいたい仏教徒は一応暗記する芸なんです
あの本書いてますよ こういう経典全部まとめて
私は ある経典の一部なんです
だから人間が失敗する
個人個人が失敗する この 4つの偏見というか
4つの マインドコントロールかな
洗脳ですね マインドコントロールというよりも
だって好みってどうしようもないでしょ
好みで動くんです だから嫌な気持ちもあるでしょ
嫌な気持ちが出てきたら
そのままさっさっさっとやってしまうんですね
だからそういう洗脳的なエネルギーが 4つありまして
それで我々は自己管理できなくなる
それでお釈迦様はちゃんと教えてくれて
覚えてください チャンダドーサバヤモーハ
これは私にあるんだよと
気をつけると そこでセルフマネジメントが起こるんです
自己管理 自己管理とは
ちゃんとドーサ バイア
モーハを払うことなんです
それは使わないことにする
好みではなくて 事実でいくそうと
もう一つ  4つありますよ
セルフマネジメントの場合は
それは五戒の 1から 4 までになる
これを守ってくださいと
殺生しない 盗まない 欲情な行為をしない
嘘をつかない この 4つを守れば
それで八項目 完璧なセルフマネジメントなんです
もうその人は怖いものはないんです
正しい判断できる それでその人には組織を組んだ方がいいという
いわゆるなんとなく組織を組める資格が入ってくるんです
それで相反する和合と自我
和合と調和を保ちたいならば
自我の錯覚を制御しなくてはいけません
凶暴で残酷で独裁的な人は
他をまとめて動かして
自分の目的に達しようとする
あのいますよ 見事に国民をまとめる連中は独裁者なんです
我々の日本にしたっても
いろんなグループが見事にまとめられているということあるでしょ
会社よりもヤクザの組織がしっかりしているでしょ
あいまいインチキ何もないんです
みんな正直 言う通りにする
だから硬い組織ですよ
この暴力団とかは 他の組織はそれほど硬くないんです
でもどういうことですかというと
親分がいるでしょ 親分はあまりにも自我なんです
あまりにも自我があって
ものすごく自分の仲間を抑えるんです
だから仲間に自我を張ることはできないんです
仲間の自我を抑えて踏み潰して
一人の自我が強くなっていくんです
そうすると大体硬い組織が現れます
そちらには恐怖感があります
調和と和合はありません
だから暴力団などのところではしっかりした組織ですけど
調和 和合ではないんです
あるのは恐怖なんです
軍事政権の場合はね この最近までミャンマーとかね
北朝鮮とかね 今タイもね
軍事政権になっちゃって
いや いくつかの国々が結構軍事政権になってますね
軍事政権になったらすべて
だからタイではこの最近までデモ
デモ デモ 空港まで閉鎖するわ
もうバンコク街全部もう閉鎖されるわ
もうこちらから一般民俗でもあちらからデモするともうハチャメチャなんです
これでいきなり軍隊がクーデターやって政権を取っちゃったんです
その日からすべてデモが消えちゃったんです
今 タイに行ったり来たりすることもできるし
旅行することもできるし
何でもできる なんか一旦平和のように
あれ 平和を取り戻したんじゃないんです
国民が軍事政権は怖いんです
軍人だから何やっても法律はないんだから
で 常識人間がチームを組みたければ
自分のエゴがチームの中で通じないと理解しなくてはいけない
我々は暴力団を作りたくないでしょ
我々は民主主義が好きで
恐怖感が嫌で 幸福になりたいんですね
楽しい組織を作りたいんです
幸せになるチームを組みたいんです
だったら 私たちに条件があるんです
あなたのエゴを抑えてくださいと
あなたのエゴ 自我が組織では通じませんということは
セルフマネジメントとして覚えておかなくてはいけないんです
例えば 友達 3人作ろうとしましょう
じゃあ 3人で晩ご飯食べましょうと
3人で食べましょうと言った瞬間で
自分のエゴが通じません
それを理解してほしい
自分が初めからもう例えばお好み焼き食べたかったんです
ここら辺 面白いお好み焼き屋さんがいて
でもなんか一人で行くの行くのもあれだから行ったこともないし
それで 3人の組織を作るでしょ
その時点で自分のエゴがお好み焼き食いたいなというね
あれが危うい状態になるんです
それ覚悟しないと だから組合作る方法ありますよ
あるいは最初からもう私はお好み焼きを食べたい
まるまるの店で では その店に行きたい人がいる？と聞いてみれば
それでそんなに大きい問題じゃないんですね
それで誰もいないだったら
もう目的達成することはできません
それ言わずに 誰だって晩御飯食べる時間だから
じゃあ 3人で晩御飯に行きましょうかと言った瞬間で
私はお好み焼きを食べたかったということが抑える羽目になります
それわかりませんよ 二人もはい
いいですよと言ったら大成功で
お好み焼きだけはもうごめんごめん
それだけはもう勘弁してくれと言ったらアウトなんですね
だから我々 常識的な人間であるならば
社会人であるならば 文化人であるならば
どうしてもチームを作らなくちゃいかんですよ
誰だって そうすると チームを作ると同時に
自我を抑えなくてはいけないということ
はい 次のチャプターに入ります
国あるいは大きな組織
国っていうのは組織なんです
国って存在しないんです
例えば 日本という国はどこにあるんですかね
そんな場所がないんです
あれ 組織なんです 人間の
大組織の場合は皆守るべき共通ルールがあります
あの 皆様方は全然自分では日本国という組織を作ろうと思ったことないでしょ
で 我々作る組織っていうのは
せいぜい小さな小さなもので
でも世の中で大きな組織もあります
知らないうちに自分も大きな組織のメンバーになっています
例えば大きな会社に入っちゃうと
知らないうちに大きな組織のメンバーなんです
もし国会議員になったならば
大きな組織のメンバーなんです
いや 同じでどうしようもないんです
そういうふうに この大きな組織の場合はルールがあります
でお釈迦様がおっしゃったことを紹介します
これは皆様にお先にも紹介したことがあります
ワッジ共和国共和国の繁栄を目指して
インドではたった 2つあったんだけどね
共和国が 2つあったんです
我々 今考える共和国と違って
国自体が小さいんですよ
そんなに巨大な国ではないんです
しかし 王政ではないんです
議員さんたちにみんなに王と言うんです
王というよりも王子と言うんです
だから 王子たちがたくさん集めて国を運営するんです
大王様がいないんです
だから独裁者は一人もいません
ということは 現代的に言えば共和国で議会制度なんです
それでお釈迦様がこの議会制度をすごく好みなんです
あの王政独裁王政の時代で現れたお釈迦様が
なぜかでお釈迦様の国も
大体議会制度であった共和国のようなものなの
だからお釈迦様はものすごく民主主義なんです
徹しているんです しかし
当時ではそんなこと言ったっても
だから この民主主義的で
今日は議会制度の政府があって
国があったら お釈迦様は結構優しく応援する
という お釈迦様が王政独裁者がいる国に住んでいるんです
マケド国とコーサラ国ですね
二人とも独裁制度で しかし
お釈迦様が応援しているのは
もっと遠いところにあったワッジ国とマーラ国なんです
サクションが決めた 7つの項目があります
だから それでお釈迦様が政治に口を挟むことはしません
あなた方は政治家になる以前
この決まり守ってくださいと
あなた方は繁栄しますよと
倒れませんよと これで組織論を語るんです
1 アビンナンサンニパーターバビサンティサンニパーターバフラー
意味は頻繁に会合する議会を行う
かなり頻繁に行わなくちゃいけないんです
この議会の議員さんたちが頻繁に会って
頻繁に会ってくださいと
だから頻繁に議会を行うと
大体何か解決する問題というのはほとんど消えちゃうでしょ
なんかちょびちょびと問題が
あれどうしましょうかとかね
もう議会起こしちゃいますからね
ちょっと 今度はなんか雨が降りそうもないねとか
あ では議会で考え すぐそこ解決しますね
例えば洪水になって人々の家も壊れちゃって
しかし 議会は月一回だけだと
そうすると 被害を受けた人々は 1ヶ月間も待たなくちゃいかんでしょ
国が倒れます 何があったら議会やるならば反映します
ということは 解決できない問題ということはなくなるんです
に サマッガ サッニパティッサンティ
サマッガ ブッタイッサンティ
サマッガ ワッジイ カラニヤン
カリッサンティ こんなのは直訳できんだからね
サマッガっていうのは和語なんですけど
仲良く集合する 仲良く解散する
仲良く議論するなどの仕事をする
で はっきり言えば このヌワスっていうのは
例えば議会にメンバーたちが例えば 120人いるとしましょう
120人は必ず参加する
解散するときはみんな一斉に出て行く 10
人どこかでまた別な部屋に行って
コソコソこそはないんです
自民党の制度とは違うんです
みんな自分たちの恐ろしい怪しい組織
別々持ってるんですね
派閥という そこで自民党っていうのはお互い憎しみと弱肉強食というか
もうもう食い争う組織なんですね
派閥はもう派閥で なんとかもう議員さんの数を増やして力を強くしようと
共食い組織ですね はっきり言えば自民党っていうのは
こんなもんでばうまくいかないんですよ
だから日本は民主主義だから議会制度でしょ
で うまくいかないんですね
このブッダが思うほど
思うような議会ではないんです
共食いですからね 議会で敵同士ですからね
どうやって国のために議論できますかね
だから お釈迦様が考えている民主主義っていうのは世の中でないんです
私たちにあるのは民主主義ではなくて権力主義なんです
金があるか コネがあるか
なんとかなんです 最低タレントさんかとかね
タレントさんでも選挙で勝ちますからね
だからそんなのは権力主義なんです
だから代々総理大臣がある
何々大臣の家柄の家族だったら
もういとも簡単に国会議員になったりする
権力でしょう あるいはもうチャラチャラと億単位で金使えるぐらい金があると
で 選挙に参加できるというね
悲しいことですけど それは民主主義
民族デモクラシーとは言えないんです
民主主義ではないんです
民主主義ではない 民主主義だったら
能力ある人にとってはお金がなくても自転車で選挙運動できるはずなんです
自転車で疲れちゃったら
誰かにちょっとオートバイ買ってくれない？とかね
あ いいよと言って それでオートバイを買って
そこら辺の村を一回りして
はい ありがとうございますと次の村に行って
そこからちょっとオートバイで買ってくれない？とかね
言って オートバイで選挙運動してすることもできますよ
でも 億単位で金かかる
選挙運動には ですから
民主主義ではないんです
アメリカでも同じことで
はい これでお釈迦様おっしゃったのは
この組織作ったら 私たちも同じことですよ
私たちは例えば 20人のグループを作ったら
会合する時はやっぱり 20人も来てほしい
それで 20人もいろいろ議論して
やるべきことを話して
じゃあ解散って言ったら 20人も解散しなくちゃいかんです
みんな出ていると 田中さん
ちょっと待ってくださいと
話があります これはダメなんです
田中さんと何々もう片部さん
こちら来てください もう一つ話したいことがある
例えば議長やった人 秘書やった人を何かちょっとあんた二人
ちょっと私の事務所に来てくださいと言っちゃうと
他のメンバーたちはあれ？あれ何ですか？って疑問にするんです
それで和合が壊れますね
だからもし 田中さんも語り部さんも読んだ
読むならば それをみんな知っていて
実はこういうことがこの 3人で話し合わなくちゃいけないんだから
解散してからいいんじゃないかと
これの議会の時間を取る必要はないんだと
それで議会で知って そうすると解散するときであ
じゃああんた二人 あの話あれ話してくださいとみんな言うでしょ
あんた二人 会長と話して
これ何とかして で 我々帰りますよと
その場合は和合でしょ
だから微妙にお釈迦様はこのポイントを教えているんです
和合して集合する 和合して解散する
和合して仕事をすると
3番目 アパンニャッタンナパンニャーペッサンティパンニャッタンナサムッチンダッサンティヤターパンニャッテーポーラーニワジダンメーサマーダエワッティッサン
ティ
いまだかつてない法律を作らない
今の法律を破らない 先人が決めた大事な決まりを重んじて守る
組織とは 国みたいな大きい組織っていうのは我々作ったものじゃないでしょ
例えばなんとか大学とかね
何だったかな 思い出せません
早稲田大学ありますね
組織ですよ 今の人々作った大学じゃないでしょ
だから早稲田大学がもうかなり前出来上がった大学で
その組織が作った人々亡くなったんだけど
まだまだ大学がある やっぱり早稲田大学を初めて開校した立派な方々の気持ち
目的守った方がいいんです
道祖も壊しちゃって まるっきり違う組織にしたらあかんです
ですから この法律の場合は
これは仏教のサンガにも合わせる合わせてお釈迦様おっしゃってますけど
なんか好き勝手にいい加減この法律作るなよと
こうこうなりません こうこうでなければいけません
ああでなければ そんな決まりが増えれば増えるほど
組織の運営が難しいんです
だからいくつか簡単なルールがルールがあって
それから今までやったこともありまして
先人たちの知恵もあるし
経験もあるし そういうことを守ってやると
なんとなく自分のわがままではない
何かに自分たちは管理されているんだっていうことが出てくるんです
だから それ  3番目の決まり
4番目 イエー テワッジーナンワッジマハッラカ
テサッカーディサンティガルカリサンティマネスサンティプージェサンティ
テサンジュソータバンマンニサンティ
先輩年上の方々を尊敬する
彼らのアドバイスを必ず聞く
バリさんは省略したんだけど
このワッジ国なんですよ
ワッジ国の議会の方々ではなくて
議会を辞めている 退職しているおじさんたちもいますよ
例えば ある議会の議員さん
王子様のお父さんがいるでしょ
おじいさんもいるでしょ
でも政治には参加しない
家で牛の面倒を見ているんです
牛の飲みを取っているんです
おじい様が家で牛の飲みを取っているかもしれませんだけど
かつて議員でしたからね
今孫議員やってますからね
その孫がこの先輩の方々のアドバイスを大事にしなくちゃいけない
お釈迦様が言うのは 拝みなさい
礼をしなさいと 議会に行く場合は
先輩の自分の家の中でね
お父さんかおじいさんとかね
かつての議員さんがいるならば
ちゃんと土下座させて礼をして
ではおじいさん 仕事に行ってまいりますと
そこを会ってほしいと
いわゆる先輩を尊敬する
日本にしたっても 皆様方
作った世界じゃないでしょ
皆様方のお父様たちやらおじい様たちやら
そういう方々 一生懸命苦労したして作った世界でしょ
だからそういう方々に頭を下げて礼をして
生きていた方が幸せになります
5番目 ヤータークラッティヨ
クラクマリヨ ターナオッカス
オッカッサパサイエワッスワーセッサンディ
ワッジ族の娘たちを無理に強引に連れて同棲することはしません
これは道徳を守ること
弱い立場の人々の権利を守ること
権力者は権力を不正に使わないことなんです
言っているのは そこでワッジのあの国の議員さんたちはみんな若いんです
年取ると引退するんです
若者はやっぱりお嫁さん何人か欲しいでしょう
だから議員さんだから権力を持ってるでしょ
だから好きな女の人 あんた家に来いとかね
行きたくないだったら連れて行くとかね
警察が来て連れて行って同棲するとか
そうすると 権力のない人
弱い人を法律で 権力でいじめたことになるでしょ
これやめなさいと わかりやすい例を出しちゃったんです
好き勝手に女の人を家に連れて行くこと
それで全部読めると思います
権力者は権利を絶対不正に使ってはいけないんです
6番目 ヤーニターネワッジーナンワッジワッジチェーティヤーニアビーアッバンタラーニチェーヴァバーヒーラーニチャターニサッカリサンティガルーカリサンティマネスサンティプージェサン
ティ
テーサンジュディンナプッバンカタプッバンダンミカンバリンナパリハペッサンティー
ワッジ国の中 または国の外
ワッジ族の霊地聖地があるならば
それらのところに礼をしたり
供養したりする これでこの国民の文化なんです
文化壊すなよと 宗教はあるかないか
霊地に神様がいるかないか
そんなのお釈迦様にどうでもいいんです
例えば神社の祭りは仏教的には OK です
神社に神がいるかいないかどうでもいいんです
神社の祭りっていうのは日本人の文化なんです
それを大事にしなさいっていう話なんです
だからワッジ国にワッジ民族が礼拝する拝む
お祈りする いろんな場所がある
ワッジ国の外にもそういうインドですから
聖地がある そういうところにちゃんと行きなさいよと
言って このちゃんとその年行事とかあるならば
それは欠かさず行ってください
あんた方は繁栄しますよと
それからそういう人間見るところだったら
運営するために品物が必要でしょ
お布施が必要でしょ もし国がそういうところに炎上する
お布施する習慣があったならば
続けてくださいとか で
なぜそんなことをあえて言うのかというと
ワッジ族が仏教なんです
仏教は科学的な宗教で迷信が一切ないんです
これで我々は何も信じませんよということになっちゃうと
大変なことになります
だから あなた方の文化的な
信仰的な たとえ迷信でいいんです
そういうしきたり 習慣しっかりと守ってくださいと
だから日本でもね 靖国神社にちゃんと年一回参拝することをしますね
あれはこれに入りません
あれは誰かをいじめる目的で
誰かを傷つける 傷つける目的でやっているんであって
神様にとって侮辱なんです
まあ神様はいると思ってないんだけど
だいたい死んだ人々のあれさえも安置してあるでしょうね
あれは死者に対する侮辱です
はっきり言うと やっぱり文化的な行事として
一般国民も参加する 気持ちよく参加して
仲間の意識を意識が固めなくちゃあかんです
だから靖国神社参拝っていうのは
国民が参加する国家行事であれば
全然構いません いろいろね
各学校の子供たちも行進パレードであったり
平和の祈りとかね そういうふうにやるならば全然問題ないんだけど
これはやっぱりあんまり信じてない
そういう方 まあとにかく
だから気をつけてほしいところは
日本の方々もいろんな宗教儀式に参加するんだけど
そういう気持ちはもうちょっと改めた方がいいんですね
日本人の文化を守らなくちゃいけない
地方の文化を守らなくちゃいけない
地方の人々はお互い仲良く知り合って繁栄しなくちゃいけない
だから神社の祭りをみんなで派手にやりましょうよと
毎年できるだけ新しいバージョンに入れて入れてやりましょうよというふうに
この人間の繁栄を目指してほしい
人間が仲良くなることを目指してほしい
神社に神がいてもいなくてもどうでもいいんです
そんなのは問題ありません
御利益あってもなくてもどうでもいいんです
御利益あるんです みんな和合を保つというすごい御利益
はい 最後 7番目 アラハンテースダンミカーダカーワラナグッティ
まあ日本語で読みましょう
阿羅漢聖者たちを守る
この国に訪れたことがない聖者たち
来てほしい 来られた聖者たちが楽に生活してほしいと思い
その手配をする だから仏教の国だから
この聖者たちに気楽に国に出入りできるようにしてくださいと
これは仏教的なポイントで
人間に幸福を教えることできるのはお釈迦様か仏弟子たちだけなんです
他みんなエゴイストたちで
人間に幸せを教えることはできません
その上 阿羅漢たちがいるならば
もう話にならない 素晴らしいんです
だから 阿羅漢たちは自由自在に出入りできるようにしてくださいと
あなた方は決して衰退しませんよという
この組織の基本を教えたんです
これは王政 王系の王政の国のある大臣の前でお釈迦様が発表したんです
この大臣がワッジ国と戦争したかったんです
なかなか勝てないんですね
だから武力で潰そうと思ったんです
その時はなんでこの連中そんな強いのかということをお釈迦様はこればらしちゃったんですね
この七つの項目をバラしたところで
あの大臣がお釈迦様 この七つ守る必要ないんだと
一個だけでも守っているならば
あのワッジ国はもう 負けませんよと言って帰ったんです
それから一言言ったんです
ワッジ国を仲間割れすればいいでしょうにと
ワゴを壊しちゃえばいいやと
で こいつはずるい人だからワゴを壊しちゃったんです
それでワッジ国は潰れたんです
ワッジ国が潰れたのはお釈迦様のせいじゃないんです
お釈迦様の守りを人間の感情が出てきて破れてしまったんです
次 議論の仕方 発言権は皆に平等です
だから何かチームを組んで何かしなくちゃいけないんでしょ
その前に話し合うでしょ
打ち合わせあるでしょ
その場合 発言権は皆に平等にあります
人数があまりにも大きい場合は
各小さなグループで代表者を選ぶこともできます
例えば 1万人が集めたら
1万人も発言しちゃうと
何日 何日間会合するんですかね
会合の時間が例えば 2時間です
それだったら代表者を選ばなくちゃいけないんです
人の意見はあくまでも主観です
たとえ代表者が自分の意見を発表しても
自分のグループの意見でしょ
それでも主観は主観です
個人の意見は 皆 決して一斉に賛成するはずはありません
これを覚えてほしいんです
自分がチームで自分の発言はする
ああ パチパチパチパチ
素晴らしいとはないんです
自分の主観ですから だからまあ
一斉に賛成してくれると
あの勘違いはエゴなんです
自我なんです だから みんなご自分の意見があるんだから
反対する 批判する 却下することは必ずありますという謙虚な気持ちで
丁寧に自分の発言すればいいでしょう
誰か私は反対ですと言ったら
ありがとうございますと
だって反対したい人はありがとうでしょ
だって自分の意見を聞いているんだから
どういうポイントで反対でしょうかと聞けばいいでしょうに
ですから 本当に反対する人はちゃんと意見を聞いているんです
もう居眠りしている人は
国会議員さんみたいにね
はい 賛成って こんなもういいチームじゃないでしょう
賛成者 あ ちょっと間違い
賛成者の見解と反対者の見解を平等に参照する
議論の責任者たちがね
この意見の賛成者の意見
反対者の意見どうでしょうかと
ちゃんと平等に参照しなくちゃいけない
グループの共通目的に
より効果的に より早く達する方法を考えて結論を作る
結論を作る場合は これはまるまるさんの意見だから
まるまるさんは結構炎上もしていますから
やっぱり却下したらまずいでしょうとかね
あの人はたくさん政治家のことも知ってるんだから
骨があるんだから やっぱり却下したらまずいとか
いい組織じゃない あの
チャンダドーサバヤモーハで言ってるんです
そうではなくて 我々の組織は
我々のチームは この目的に達したいんだと
では この意見の中でどんな風に組み合わせたらこの目的に早く達するのかと
人のことを忘れちゃう
忘れて結論を作るんです
目的だけを見て 達した結論は
誰かの意見が通したことではありません
はい それで議長が決断を言う
この議長の決断は 会員の誰かさんの意見ではありません
これよく覚えてください
議長の意見でもありません
たとえそうであっても
それは皆の意見にしなくてはいけないのです
それで 会合の終わったところで議長が決断を読み上げる
この決断は まるまるさんが提案したそのものだとしましょう
でも もうまるまるさんの提案ではないんです
みんなの反論 異論を合わせて
それからあの関係の人々が議論して達した結論です
だから 組織の決定は組織の決定で個人には関係ないんです
覚えてほしい 達した意見はグループの意見
意見なのです 皆の意見に反対してはいけませんよ
個人では それから自分のエゴや主観を取り出して
批判したり 反対したりしてはいけません
これはとっても情けないことなんです
一旦会合で決めたのに
後で私はどちらかというと
あんまりあの考えには賛成ではありませんね
どうしようもないね みんな手を挙げたんだからとかね
私はとにかく手を引きますよとかね
なんであの連中の意見だけ
もう多数決で そんなこと言っちゃうと
もう失格なんですよ もうなんて言いますか
チームの お釈迦様ならそういう時はチームから外れるんです
出ていってくださいと
初めは反対かもしれませんよ
一旦議会で決めたら反対する権利ない
それでは皆の意見なんです
議論とは正しい意見を探し出す努力であって
自分の主観を賛成してもらう喧嘩ではありません
これは日本によくあることで
議論すると喧嘩するんですね
とにかく自分の意見を通してほしいと
あれは汚い議論なんです
議論とは正しい意見を探り出すための努力なんです
喧嘩ではありません 頑張らなくちゃあかんのです
いい意見出るまで 次 実行と結果
目的を達成するために議論して適切な結論に達すのです
実行することは皆の責任でも義務でもあります
一旦決めたら 会員みんな実行する義務があるんです
反対したい人もしょうがないんです
初めは反対したんだけど
もう賛成で決めたんだから
自分も実行しなくちゃあかんのです
仕事を分担して 各個人の能力で簡単にこなせるパートを与える
それから仕事を分担して
これは誰にできる？と聞いて
あ 私にできます はい お願いしますと
これは誰にできる？じゃあ私がやります
はい あなたにお願いします
というふうに 仕事を簡単にできるできる人に分けて分けて分けて分けてあげるんです
自分の分担を組織の皆の繁栄を願って
自我を抑えて実行するのです
それで 例えば私に与えられた仕事はポスターを折ることだとしましょう
1万枚ポスターがあって
これ四つに折らなくちゃいけない
あんた頭悪いんだから何もできんだからね
年寄りだからどこかに座って
この 1万枚のポスターを四つに折ってください
それ 私に与えられた義務ですけど
何も文句は これはみんなのための仕事で
みんなの繁栄のためにやることだという気持ちを持って
一枚一枚丁寧に四つに折る
折ってバンドを貼って
はい 仕事を完了しましたと
そうすると組織から来て
どうあなたの仕事は？と
はい 完了しました ありがとうと持ってくだけ
だから自分のパート とても謙虚で
とてもなんとなく組織の繁栄を願って
尊い気持ちでやらなくちゃあかんです
組織全体が各人の仕事を評価して認めなくてはいけません
それで組織全体がね 仕事をうまくいったら
各仕事をした人々をみんなにみんなを褒めなくちゃあかんです
組織で褒める 個人で褒めてほしいということはダメなんです
よくあることで 誰かにいい顔を見せたくて
組織の中で活動をする
そういう組織が壊れます
仕事終わったら 行事が終わったら
組織の反省会とか何だらかんだらありますからね
その時 全体的に何々さんがこれこれやっていただきました
素晴らしいことでした
ありがとうございますと
何々さんがこれこれやっていただきました
大変助かりました ありがとうございますと
組織全体で褒めなくちゃあかんです
少ない努力で高い結果が得ることができます
この段取り踏んじゃうと
必ずみんな楽々に高い結果を出すんです
至って簡単で これは組織のやり方なんです
えっと もう時間になりましたね
じゃああと何枚かありますから
その休憩なしに読み上げます
和合はどこまでというね
共通する目的があってグループを組みますでしょ
その目的に達したら グループの仕事は終わります
解散しても構わない 例えば盆踊りやりましょうよと
50人がグループを組む
そこで 1ヶ月間も準備して徹夜もして
いろいろなことをして盆踊りをやる
それから後片付けもする
反省会もやる お互い組織で褒めてもらったりもする
それで解散です それからも盆踊り会の和合っていうのは意味はありません
だから和合はどこまでもということは要りません
一回仲良く活動して 良い結果も出せたならば
仲間が互いに知っているんです
でも一つありますよ 盆踊り大会やったら
お互い頑張ったということは互い知ってますね
それで別な和合が生まれるかもしれません
それから別な目的で人間関係を築いても構わない
あ あの人を呼べばいいでしょうと
あの人を呼びましょうとかね
でも 盆踊り祭りの組合はもう終わりです
やって終わったんだから
長らく続くべき和合と調和
調和と和合 だから前説明したのは一時的な和合
一時的な調和 盆踊り実行委員会みたいでね
盆踊り終わったら終わり
一時的 世の中にありますよ
長らく続けてほしい 調和と和合
人類の幸福を目指す組織は長らく続くべきです
人類全体の幸福を目指す組織
人類を幸せにしましょう
人類に平和をつくりましょう
人類を豊かにしましょう
という組織は長くあってほしいんです
道徳を守る目的 心を成長させる目的などは
個人だけではなく 人類のためでもあります
例えば 私は道徳を守る組織を作ったら
私の組織が道徳を守ることで他の人も助かりますよ
だからそのような組織
心育ちましょうよと そのような組織は長らく続けてほしい
このような組織には時間制限があってはならないんです
しかし 一切無常なので
永遠に続く組織はありません
それは別な話で 私たちは心成長する組織
道徳を守る組織 世界に平和をもたらす組織
世界を豊かにする組織などなどは
長らく生き続けるようにと頑張らなくちゃいけない
決して解散してはいけません
とは言ったっても 世の中は無常だからね
それはそれで はい 衰退しないサンガ組織
サンガの和合 サンガは衰退しないんで
奨学者であるお釈迦様がサンガの基礎
基礎規則を作ったのです
会議を改革する権利は弟子であるサンガにありません
お釈迦様が作ったんです
我々は弟子です だから師匠に教えてあげる権利はないんです
サンガは時代にと要求に応じて何かを決めることがあっても
それは全世界のすべての比丘サンガが認めて守るものにならなくてはいけない
例えば タイのお坊さんたちがサンガがでサンガで何か決めたとしましょう
それがミャンマーでもスリランカでも
カンボジアでもアメリカのお坊さんでも
誰でも やっぱりあのお決まりは素晴らしい
みんなで守りましょうというふうな決まりでなければいけません
冗談じゃないで 国連の決まりより難しいんです
サンガの決まりは  現実的に言えば改革不可能です
サンガの改革不可能です
だから我々はこの衣も 2500年もデザインしないで
着ているんです 現代に合わせてね
膝のところで止まれるようにとか
あるいはこれもこうやってチャックでジリジリっと
それはできないんです
簡単で こちらもチャックで留めて
こちらもチャックで留めて
膝のところで終わりと
いざって簡単でしょ？洗濯も簡単でしょうしね
できません その権利ないんです
私がそんな衣を作ったっても
他のお坊さんたちは否定するんです
だから成り立ちません
だからずっと同じパターンで続くんです
えーと 改革は不可能です
お釈迦様の指示に従って
皆解脱を目的にして精進しなくてはならない組織です
だから目的があります
サンガ組織にも解脱に達するという
だから集めたんです だからチームを組んだんです
その目的を目指してみんな頑張っているんです
だから和合と調和は崩れません
解脱を目指す限り サンガ組織は衰退しない
これはブッダの言葉です
比丘たちが解脱を目指す限り
サンガ組織は衰退しませんよと
時代がどんな時代になっても
IT になっても  iPhone 時代になっても
サンガ組織は衰退しない
真似できないサンガの和合
残念なことに サンガの和合というのは人間に真似できないんです
理由書きます サンガは貪瞋痴を捨てる目的のグループです
サンガというのは貪瞋痴を捨てる目的グループなんです
俗世間は貪瞋痴の衝動で貪瞋痴を達成するための組織です
どうやって真似するんですか？できないでしょ
俗世間のチームは全部貪瞋痴のためなんです
貪瞋痴は和合調和ではなく
争い 愛着 わがまま 戦争を引き起こす感情です
だから貪瞋痴は和合できません
貪瞋痴では戦いはできます
わがままはできます だからサンガの真似はなかなか難しい
サンガは議論するとき
自分の意見ではなく 仏教の立場は何なのかと議論するんです
これ 皆様にできない 皆様のチームでは
何々さんの意見 何々さんの意見
何々さんの意見なんですね
私たちサンガは議論するときは
あれ この場合どうしましょうかねとかね
お釈迦様はどういうふうに言ってるんでしょうかと
それで この間も私たちはコロナのとき
会談に行ったとき 私は一応全部儀式を行ったんだけど
いきなり文章の言葉を言っている途中でカチッとなって
あれ これどうしようかと
というところで みんな若い者もみんなお互い話し合って議論したんです
安田さんもワンゲーさん見たんだけど
シンハラ語だからわからなかったと思いますけど
あのちょっと 30秒我々議論したんです
議論は何なのかというと
この場合はブッダの意見ならどういうことかと
だから私がこうした方がいいんじゃないって気持ちはあったんだけど
私は止めた えっ これちょっとストップやと
それで若者みんな集めて
うーん こうあります こうあります
こうありますとかね 私は一応学者だからね
この人こう書いてますけど
まあここは本当はこうなりますということで
こういうことでしょうね
お釈迦様の気持ちではとか
そうですね ではそれでいきますと終わり
だからあっという間に議論して和合で終わっちゃうんです
だからみんな話し合うの好きなんで
その場合は だってお互い様
ブッダの意見は何なのかを調べるだけだから
私の意見は存在しないんです
だから本当に客観的な議論できますよ
俗世間では無理です 必ず和合で終了します
これ決まってます サンガの場合は必ず和合で終了します
はい サンガの組織は完全たる絶対的なものです
サンガ組織っていうのは完全だけではなく
絶対的なんです メンバーである比丘は個人です
だから私は個人でサンガが絶対的なんです
個人の生き方 失敗 誤りに対して個人が責任を負うんです
私は個人です 私の誤り
私の失敗 私は責任を持ちます
もし私は衣半分に切っちゃって尻尾をつけたならば
その責任を私が負います
サンガは私を却下するだけ
個人の過ちはサンガの過ちではありません
だから私は衣が上着のように作ったならば
サンガを侮辱したら大変なことになるんです
それだったら私を侮辱した方がいいんです
お前がけしからんのと
今のサンガは誰しなと言った途端
すごい重罪を犯したことになるんです
だから あくまでも個人の誤りは個人のもので
絶対的なサンガには関係ないんです
個人の過ちはサンガの過ちではありません
俗世間ではあまり個人個人区別しないんですよ
俗世間では 私たちみたいに明確に切って分けることはないんです
自我で個人の過ちを組織の過ちにしたり
組織の過ちを個人の過ちにしたりもしますでしょ
日本ではよくあることでしょ
個人が間違って組織が潰れるとかね
あるいは組織が変なことをしたら
誰か 誰か人を犯人に仕立てて
そういうことを汚いことをやっていますよ
俗世間では それはサンガでは起きません
はい それから正しいチームって何なのかと
幸福と繁栄を目指して
衰退してはならない正しいチームなんです
皆 慈しみを実践するために
実行するためにグループを組む
生命は生きている限り慈しみは必要です
そういうグループは衰退しないし
長らく続きます 心を成長すること
汚れを落とすことを目指してグループを組む
目的に達した人は先輩
指導者になるだけで グループを解散する必要はありません
例えば 悟りに達しましょうと仲間はグループを作るでしょう
悟りに達したらグループ解散はないんです
悟りに達した人はただ指導者になる
まだみんな頑張ればいいんです
それでみんなも悟りに達した
解散する必要ないんで
みんな指導者たちなんです
まだ悟りに達してない人々を入れちゃえばいいんです
完全な心で生まれる生命はいないので
組織に長らく会員はいるんです
だから完全な人間は生まれませんだから
例えば解脱に達する組織を作ったら
いくらでも長持ちします
だって修行して解脱に達するんだからね
生まれてくる 生まれてくる
みんな不完全な人間で
だから会員になれる 会員になったら先輩もいる
指導者もいる そういう組織なら衰退しないし
長らく続けてほしいし
長らく続けられます はい
これで終了だと思います
はい 非常に難しい話になりましたけど
簡単だと思ったんです
かなり組織論もややこしいんです
一応我々に自我があるんだだから困っているだけで
最低自我を抑えておけばいい組織が作られますよ
頑張ってみてください
どうもありがとうございます
スマナサーラ先生 ありがとうございました
それではちょうど時間となってしまいましたので
今日はすいませんが 質疑応答の時間は割愛させていただきたいと思います
それでは皆さんで最後に回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の等しい生きるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますよう
そして解脱が得られますよう
サッビーキョーワンジャンツーサッバローボーウィナッセットーマーテーバワットワンタラーヨーシュケーディーガイコーバワーバウディサッバマンガラムラッカント
ゥサンバデヴァタサンバブッダヌバーヴェーナサンバダンマヌバーヴェーナサンバサンガヌバーヴェーナサダースッティバワントゥテーアウィーワダナシーリスーニッチ
ャンワッダパチャイノーチャッターローダンマーワッダンティアイワンノーシュカンバラン
はい ありがとうございます